Sie sind krank
und wollen nichts als leben.
Sie warten auf ein Organ,
das ein Verstorbener spendet.
Ein Leben geht zu Ende,
eines wird verlängert.
Die Organtransplantation
ist ein Eingriff, der bewegt.
Es geht um Ethik, Glaube,
Gesetz und Moral.
Um grosses Glück ...
Ich freue mich wie verrückt
auf diesen nächsten Lebensabschnitt.
Ich bin sehr dankbar,
dass ich das alles erleben darf.
... und um Ängste.
Was bedeutet die Transplantation
für die Empfängerinnen und Empfänger?
Wie genau läuft sie ab?
Wir hatten den Schnitt
um ca. 20.20 Uhr.
Und die Leber ist sehr schön.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Es braucht wahnsinnig Geduld.
Wie ist die Lebensqualität
nach dem grossen Eingriff?
Es geht um Warten,
Hoffnung und vielleicht - Erlösung.
"Es tut mir leid, dass ich
nicht immer das starke Vorbild bin,
für das mich viele hier halten."
"Manchmal, ja, da habe ich
ganz gehörig die Schnauze voll."
"Momente, in denen ich
aus meinem Körper ausbrechen
und ganz weit wegrennen möchte
und vielleicht auch einfach einmal
ein bisschen normal sein will."
Eliane Gutzwiller ist 26 Jahre alt.
Sie leidet an der Lungenkrankheit
Cystische Fibrose.
Vor fünf Jahren wurde ihr
eine Spenderlunge transplantiert,
nach langem Warten.
Mit dem Leben hatte sie damals
schon abgeschlossen.
All die Erlebnisse
teilt sie mit ihren Followern.
Das Hauptthema ist das Leben
mit einer transplantierten Lunge.
Das ist das grobe Thema.
Dann halt die Spitalaufenthalte,
die Therapie,
die ich im Moment machen muss.
Wenn ich wieder
psychische Probleme habe,
versuche ich den Leuten zu erklären,
wie das ist.
Hauptsächlich
geht es sicher um Verarbeitung,
die ich durch dieses Profil habe.
Das mag für andere vielleicht etwas
komisch klingen,
dass man alles
mit der Welt teilen muss.
Aber für mich ist das eine Art,
das Ganze zu bewältigen.
"against_normal", gegen
die Normalität, heisst Elianes Blog.
Es geht um Kleider,
Frisuren, Rezepte und Krankheit.
Ich habe gemerkt, dass ich
damit Leuten Mut machen kann,
die selbst etwas haben.
Und dass ich anderen,
die dasselbe haben wie ich,
die vielleicht
noch nicht transplantiert sind,
Kraft schenke und ihnen zeige,
dass man
nicht nur die Krankheit ist,
sondern dass man auch
eine Person ist.
Eliane Gutzwiller
möchte leben wie alle andern auch.
Aber der Körper macht ihr
einen Strich durch die Rechnung.
Er will die transplantierte Lunge
nicht mehr akzeptieren.
Seit Februar habe ich jetzt
eine chronische Abstossung.
Deshalb gehe ich
in eine sog. Lichttherapie,
wo die weissen Blutkörperchen
so verändert werden,
dass sie nicht mehr
gegen die Lunge wirken.
Das dauert immer zwei Tage.
Dafür packe ich mein Köfferchen
oder viel mehr den Rucksack.
Chronische Abstossung.
Ein Schock, aber kein Todesurteil,
sagt Eliane.
Man kann nicht sagen, wie lange man
mit der Abstossung leben kann.
Aber das kann man ja
sonst auch nicht.
Ich könnte vom Bus überfahren
werden, dann wäre es auch vorbei.
(Durchsage)
Nächster Halt: Zürich Hauptbahnhof.
Die Diagnose
hat Eliane Gutzwiller zurückgeworfen.
Aber die neue Therapie hält
die chronische Abstossung in Schach.
Photopherese heisst die Behandlung,
eine Art Blutwäsche.
Die weissen Blutzellen
werden ausserhalb des Körpers
mit einer Substanz versetzt
und mit UVA-Licht bestrahlt.
Dafür braucht Eliane einen sog. Port,
ein Kathetersystem unter der Haut.
Der wurde gelegt, weil ich relativ
schlechte Venen an den Armen haben.
Bei diesen Therapien müssen
die Venen etwas stabiler sein.
Die Gefahr, dass meine Venen
platzen, ist relativ gross.
Deshalb hat man den Port gelegt.
Eliane hat dem Port
einen Namen gegeben: Jason Justin.
Ich konnte dann
viel besser damit umgehen.
Mit diesem Fremdkörper,
den ich hier habe.
Es ist ... Ja ...
Irgendwie konnte ich es mit Humor
nehmen, als er einen Namen hatte.
Die Therapie macht müde.
Andere Nebenwirkungen hat sie nicht.
Das muss mind. 20 Min. drinbleiben.
* Eliane stimmt leise zu. *
Die Photopherese
kann die chronische Abstossung
nicht zum Verschwinden bringen,
aber immerhin bremsen.
Es gibt mir Hoffnung,
dass die Lungenfunktion
in der nächsten Zeit
nicht weiter sinkt.
Doch eine Garantie hat man ja nie.
Das Blut läuft durch diese Maschine.
* Leises Rattern *
Eliane gibt nicht auf.
Im schweizerischen Kinderleberzentrum
in Genf warten Mireya und ihre Eltern
seit Tagen sehnsüchtig
auf die Erlaubnis heimzukehren.
Ich denke,
es ist langsam Zeit, heimzukehren.
Aber die Ärzte müssen natürlich
sagen, ob alles in Ordnung ist.
Ich denke schon.
Das sagt sie schon lange, was?
(Lachend) Schon seit Samstag.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Mireya leidet
an einer gefährlichen Gen-Krankheit.
Nur eine Lebertransplantation
kann sie retten.
Der Eingriff verläuft gut.
Nach einer Woche aber
gibt es Komplikationen.
Mireya muss noch mal operiert werden.
Mireya.
- Hallo, Maminko.
Hallo, Schätzelinko.
Voilà.
Die Zeit im Spital
ist für alle schwer.
Sie sagen immer irgendwas
und dann kommen sie nicht.
Die Arztvisite ist überfällig.
Was?- Die sagen immer etwas
und dann kommen sie nicht.
* Stöhnen *
Einen Monat verbringt die ganze
Familie jetzt schon im Spital.
Bonjour.
* Lachen *
(Arzt) Hallo Mireya.
- Hallo.
Alors écoutez.
Nous on a que des bonnes nouvelles.
Alors, wir überbringen heute
die Nachrichten.
Gute Nachrichten.
- Ah, Sie haben es verstanden.
Sie sprechen jetzt auch Französisch.
Et puis ...
... on voulait vous dire,
que le pois
a un peu diminué.
Mireyas Gewicht
hat etwas abgenommen.
Ça veut dire que le liquide
à l'intérieur a diminué aussi.
Die Flüssigkeit im Bauch
wurde auch geringer.
Super.
Ça veut dire que pour nous
c'est tout okay,
pour vous que vous puissiez aller.
D'accord?
Für uns sind alle Punkte okay
und Sie können nach Hause.
Es braucht eine Kontrolle pro Woche
bis drei Monate
nach der Transplantation.
Kontrollen,
die in Luzern stattfinden können.
Ich habe auch noch eine Frage.
Darf ich Süssigkeiten essen?
Darf sie Zucker essen?
- Süssigkeiten. Haribo oder ...
Si elle peut manger
des chauses sucrés? Oui, oui.
Ja? Nicht so viel.
Ein wenig, ja.
On va controller le sucre aussi
une fois par semaine.
Der Zucker wird auch
einmal pro Woche kontrolliert.
Mit einer Blutabnahme.
Wie wir früher schon gesagt haben:
Im Fall von Fieber,
Erbrechen oder Durchfall
müssen Sie immer ins Spital.
Super.
Auf Wiedersehen!
- Merci.
Danke schön. Danke.
- Danke.
(Ärztin) Wir sehen uns noch.
Yes!
- Bravo.
Jetzt habe ich ...
Jetzt, jetzt habe ich ...
Jetzt habe ich Lust auf alles.
(Navigationssystem)
Die Route wird berechnet.
Jahrelang hatten die Eltern Angst,
Mireya zu verlieren.
Sie hofften auf die Transplantation.
Bangten während der Eingriffe.
Jetzt endlich ist es vorbei.
Es geht es nach Hause.
# Gehen wir nach Hause.
Nach Hause, nach Hause.
* Helle Klänge *
Und wenn ich sehe,
wie viel Arbeit auf mich zukommt ...
Bekommst du die Krise?
Willst du gleich wieder hier runter?
Nein.
- Dann wird es nicht langweilig.
Lieber ...
- Lieber zu Hause bleiben?
Ja. Zu Hause
ist immer der beste Ort.
Egal, wo man ist, zu Hause ist ...
... der beste Ort.
- Definitiv.
Ankunft in Emmenbrücke.
Katjas Bruder hat die Wohnung
und Hund Rocco gehütet.
Rocco!
Aufpassen!
Hoi.
* Keuchen *
Wer ist das?
- Rocco.
Na, kennst du sie noch?
Das ist Mireya.
Beruhige dich, Rocco.
- Das dauert noch lange.
Rocco, trink etwas!
Katja schimpft.
Die Wohnung
ist ihr nicht sauber genug.
* Sie sprechen eine fremde Sprache. *
Katastrophe.
V.a. die Küche
muss blitzblank werden.
Mireyas Abwehrkräfte sind geschwächt.
Jetzt wird er nervös.
- Bin ich auch.
Aufpassen, nicht dass er kommt.
Das ist unser richtiger Hund.
Ja. Wie er leibt und lebt.
Unsere Familie ist wieder zusammen.
Rapperswil am Zürichsee.
Christian Reutemann
wartet auf eine Spenderlunge.
* Christian atmet schwer. *
Das ist
mein mobiles Sauerstoffgerät.
Jetzt gehe ich die Post holen.
Da sind dabei:
mein Telefon
und mein ... Notfallspray.
Diese Sachen habe ich immer dabei,
wenn ich zur Tür hinausgehe.
So kann ich immer,
wenn etwas passiert,
jemanden anrufen
und somit Hilfe holen.
Reutemann ist 51.
Seit zehn Jahren leidet er an COPD,
einer chronisch obstruktiven
Lungenkrankheit.
Das Haus hat keinen Lift.
Bewegung wird zur Qual.
Das ist Station 1.
Hier mache ich eigentlich
immer eine kurze Pause.
Rund um die Uhr ist er
auf das Sauerstoffgerät angewiesen.
Ganz am Anfang
habe ich mich gefragt: "Warum ich?"
Diese Frage
kann man nicht beantworten.
Sie führt nirgendwo hin.
Ich war auch wütend ...
... als ich gemerkt habe,
dass ich etwas nicht mehr schaffe.
Aber das bringt genauso wenig.
Man muss versuchen,
nach vorne zu schauen,
das Positive zu sehen.
Wobei es bei dieser Krankheit
eigentlich nur eine Prognose gibt.
COPD ist unheilbar.
Christian Reutemanns Ehe
ist vor zwei Jahren zerbrochen.
Seine Ex-Frau ist aber immer noch
Tag und Nacht da für ihn,
wenn er in Atemnot gerät.
* Anschwellende, bedrückende Klänge *
Das Leben ist geschrumpft.
Die Arbeit als leitender Angestellter
in der IT von Tchibo
musste er vor vier Jahren aufgeben.
Die Wohnung verlässt er kaum mehr.
Früher spielte Christian Reutemann
Tuba.
U.a. auch
bei der Stadtmusik Rapperswil.
Er habe wild gelebt,
geraucht und gekifft.
Dazu steht er.
Die Gedanken,
"Hätte ich nicht geraucht" usw.,
habe ich mir gemacht.
Aber daran denkt man mit 20 nicht -
ich zumindest nicht.
Das hat COPD gefördert,
aber ich habe es nicht nur deswegen.
Rund 90 % der COPD-Patienten haben
geraucht oder rauchen immer noch.
Neben der Musik
war eine Modelleisenbahn
Christian Reutemanns grosses Hobby.
Zurzeit aber steht alles still.
Nach der Transplantation gibt es
unten durch einen Schattenbahnhof.
Da werden alle Züge abgestellt.
Dann kommen sie auf diese Etage.
Da gibt es einen grossen Kreis,
wo der Bahnhof sein wird.
Ich denke, in dieser Region hier
gibt es eine schöne Fahrstrecke.
Hier einen schönen grossen Bogen.
Hinten durch.
Dann wieder hier.
Das ist ein Ziel dieser Operation.
Es fehlt ihm die Kraft,
die Anlage zusammenzusetzen.
Der Kiosk ist separat beleuchtet,
die grosse Halle
ist separat beleuchtet.
Das sind Dinge,
die man eher im Sitzen machen kann.
Aber hier bauen, machen -
das schaffe ich jetzt nicht.
Ja.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Christian Reutemann
ist seit fast einem Jahr
auf der Warteliste
für eine Lungentransplantation,
zurzeit mit 45 anderen Patientinnen
und Patienten.
Die durchschnittliche Wartezeit
beträgt gut ein Jahr.
* Tropfende Klavierklänge *
* Stimmengewirr *
Auf der Intensivstation
des Inselspitals Bern
liegt ein Patient im Koma.
Sein Sohn erinnert sich, Monate
später, an den dramatischen Tag.
Er ging alleine Skifahren.
Und er kam nicht zurück.
Meine Mutter rief an und sagte:
"Papi ist nicht zurückgekommen."
Meine erste Reaktion war:
"Wir müssen schauen!"
"Winter, Skifahren, kalt. Bevor es
dunkel wird, müssen wir ihn finden."
Im ersten Moment denkt man,
dass er ein Bein gebrochen hat,
in ein Tobel gefallen ist.
Das Handy hat er immer dabei,
nimmt es auch immer ab.
Wir haben ihn jedoch nie erreicht.
Irgendwann hat jemand geantwortet.
Es war das Inselspital.
Sie hat gefragt, was los sei,
ob er die Beine gebrochen habe.
Sie haben gesagt, es sei schlimmer.
Hirnblutung, so die Diagnose.
Schnell war klar,
dass der Vater von Patric von Reding
nicht überleben wird.
Die Ärzte sprachen mit den
Angehörigen über eine Organspende.
Die Familie stimmte zu.
Der Hirnschaden war irreversibel, der
Hirntod aber noch nicht eingetreten.
Damit durfte auch der Organspende-
prozess noch nicht gestartet werden.
Hier haben wir den Patienten
mit der intracerebralen Blutung,
mit Ventrikeleinbruch.
Wir heute Angehörigengespräche
geführt
und im Sinne des Patienten eine
organerhaltende Therapie begonnen.
Die Angehörigen sind noch da
und eigentlich gut informiert.
Organerhaltende Therapie heisst:
Der Patient bleibt an den Maschinen.
Er wird beatmet,
der Kreislauf stabilisiert.
Die Familie des Patienten
musste innert Stunden entscheiden,
ob eine Organspende infrage kam
oder nicht.
Er hatte keinen Ausweis.
Man wusste es also nicht.
Das hätte es uns erleichtert.
Dass wir gewusst hätten,
er möchte eine Organspende.
Er war sein Leben lang
ein sehr hilfsbereiter Mensch.
Er wollte immer allen helfen.
Und wir dachten,
das wäre in seinem Sinn gewesen,
trotz aller Traurigkeit,
obwohl man nichts mehr ändern kann,
anderen Menschen helfen.
Deshalb war die Sache für uns klar,
und wir haben die Organspende
einleiten lassen.
Wer die Nachricht erhält, dass
ein geliebter Mensch verstorben sei,
ist schnell überfordert,
wenn in einem zweiten Gespräch die
Frage nach einer Organspende kommt.
Oft wissen die Angehörigen nicht,
was der Verstorbene wollte.
Mathias Nebiker
ist mit solchen Situationen vertraut.
Auch für die Intensivmediziner
können die Gespräche belastend sein.
In der Öffentlichkeit
besteht der Eindruck:
Organspende wollen die Ärzte,
das will die Medizin.
Ich glaube, das muss jeder
für sich selbst entscheiden.
Wenn er das will,
ermöglichen wir das.
Sobald die Zustimmung
für eine Organspende da ist,
läuft eine Frist von 48 Std.
Tritt der Hirntod
in dieser Zeit nicht ein,
lässt man den Patienten sterben.
Das ist eine Frist,
die so definiert wurde.
Teilweise ist nicht klar,
wie sich der Hirndruck entwickelt.
Manchmal geht es schnell,
manchmal tritt es nicht ein.
So ist es für alle geregelt:
Wenn nach 48 Std.
nicht der Hirntod eintritt,
kann man leider
keine Organspende machen,
auch wenn das der Wunsch
des Patienten gewesen wäre.
* Rhythmische,
monotone Klavierklänge *
Warten auf den Hirntod.
Für die Angehörigen eine Strapaze.
Am schlimmsten waren die Nächte.
Wir hatten vereinbart,
dass sich die Pflegerin oder der
Pfleger sofort meldet, wenn er geht.
Und man hatte immer das Handy
auf dem Nachttisch oder bei sich.
Man erwartet jede Minute,
dass das Telefon klingelt.
Doch es ruft niemand an.
Das war eine sehr intensive
und schwere Zeit.
48 Std.
Zwei Nächte, zwei Tage.
Sie können endlos scheinen.
Tatsächlich lief die Zeit,
ohne dass der Hirntod eintrat.
Es kam nicht zur Organspende.
Da ist sicherlich
ein gewisser Frust da.
Man hat sich das Ziel der
organherhaltenden Therapie gesetzt.
Man hat erwartet, dass der Hirntod
innerhalb der 48 Std. eintritt.
Man hat Gespräche mit der Familie
geführt, hat sie darauf vorbereitet.
Und jetzt tritt dieses Ereignis
innerhalb dieser Zeitspanne
nicht ein.
Ja. Es ist ein gewisser Frust da.
Jetzt muss man
mit der Familie reden
und die neue Situation, in der
wir uns befinden, zu besprechen.
Dass die gesetzte Frist verstreicht,
kommt durchschnittlich
etwa jedes sechste Mal vor.
In diesen Fällen
wird ein Leben vergeblich verlängert.
Wenn man die Therapie
vorher abgebrochen hätte,
wäre der Patient verstorben -
davon ist auszugehen.
Bald werden die Maschinen abgestellt.
Kurz darauf wird der Patient sterben.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Zwar ist eine Organspende
nach dem Kreislauftod
unter gewissen Voraussetzungen
möglich.
Diesen Prozess hat vor Kurzem
auch das Inselspital eingeführt.
Aber in diesem Fall
wurde davon abgesehen.
Patric von Reding und seine Frau
sind im Reinen mit dem Geschehenen.
Die 48 Std. waren sehr speziell.
Die möchte man niemandem zumuten.
Aber rückblickend sehe ich
die Wichtigkeit des Ganzen trotzdem.
Ich selbst würde mich wieder
für diesen Weg entscheiden.
Ich sage manchmal: Vielleicht wollte
er als Person doch nicht spenden.
Darum hat er die 48 Std. gewartet.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Hunzenschwil in der Nähe von Aarau.
Eliane Gutzwiller
wohnt seit letztem Frühjahr allein.
Sie lebt von der IV.
Für den Beruf
fehlen zurzeit die Kräfte.
Ich arbeite seit Längerem
an einem Kinderbuch.
Ich schreibe sehr gern.
Vor ungefähr einem Jahr
habe ich das Zeichnen
für mich entdeckt.
Die Hauptfigur ist Lotta,
eine Hummel.
Es geht um ihr Schulzeit,
die sie erlebt.
Ich möchte, wenn ich
irgendwann nicht mehr da bin,
etwas hinterlassen.
Das ist vielleicht auch der Grund,
dass ich möchte,
dass es veröffentlicht wird.
Bis dahin ist es ein weiter Weg.
Aber ich möchte es probieren.
Damit etwas für meine Nichten
und Neffen übrigbleibt,
das sie von ihrer Tante
in der Hand halten können,
wenn es mich irgendwann
nicht mehr gibt.
Eine eigene Familie
wird sie nicht gründen können.
Die Krankheit
bestimmt die Lebensplanung.
Ich habe mit dem Gedanken
schon früh abgeschlossen,
einmal eigene Kinder zu bekommen.
Mit 18 wurde mir gesagt, es
sei nicht klug, Kinder zu bekommen.
Das würde mein Körper
gar nicht schaffen.
Ich wäre neun Monate im Krankenhaus.
Und es wäre fraglich,
ob ich die Geburt überleben würde.
Ich habe mich mittlerweile
damit abgefunden.
Mühe werde ich erst bekommen,
wenn die ersten Freundinnen
um mich herum Kinder bekommen.
Dann wird es für mich
nicht mehr so einfach,
wie wenn ich sie jetzt treffe.
Ich habe schon gesagt, ich möchte
von jedem Kind Gotti werden.
Dann habe ich
auf eine andere Art Kinder.
Ja.
* Ruhige Musik *
Eliane Gutzwiller ist oft unterwegs
anzutreffen - mit Freundinnen.
Mit Lena Bühler teilt sie
die Leidenschaft für Tattoos.
Das war bloss eine Idee.
- Dann fehlt nur noch "Lion King".
Hierhin?
- Nein.- Hier ist schon ein Tier.
"Solange ich atme" -
das ist das erste Tattoo,
das sich Eliane stechen liess.
Das war für mich eine Kampfansage.
Solange ich atmen kann,
egal, wie schlecht,
kämpfe ich und habe die Hoffnung,
dass eine neue Lunge kommt.
Für die Zeit nach der Transplantation
raten die Ärzte von neuen Tattoos ab.
Kennengelernt haben sich
die Freundinnen bei Instagram.
Du hast eine Story gepostet ...
- ... über ein Frisurenbuch.
Ein Frisurenbuch.
- Für 50er-Jahre-Frisuren.
Da habe ich sie gefragt,
woher sie das habe.
So kam das in Rollen.
- Genau.
Für mich sind Freunde eine gute zu-
sätzliche Stütze neben der Familie.
Ich weiss auch nicht.
Ich kann auch in den Ausgang.
Ich bin nicht nur die,
die im Krankenhaus liegt.
Ich bin auch mal die,
die nicht nur krank ist.
Logisch, bist du krank.
Aber es ist nicht immer
in meinem Hinterkopf:
"Kann sie das machen,
weil sie ja krank ist?"
Es ist schon ein Thema,
aber nicht der Hauptbestandteil
der Freundschaft.
Das will ich auch gar nicht.
Ja.
Dafür gibt es Leute,
die auch lungentransplantiert sind.
Wenn ich will,
dass es 24 Std. darum geht.
Aber das will ich nicht.
Das wollte ich schon als Kind nicht.
Ich hätte in Lager gehen können,
wo alle die gleiche Krankheit haben.
Alle mit CF.
Ich habe mich immer geweigert,
dorthin zu gehen.
Ich wollte nicht, dass es
24 Std. um dieses Thema geht.
Es sind Strategien für das Glück,
die Eliane Gutzwiller entwickelt hat.
* Melancholische Musik *
Eine zweite Lungentransplantation
schliesst sie nicht ganz aus.
Aber sie versucht,
Tag für Tag zu nehmen.
Ich mache keine grossen Pläne mehr
für die nächsten Jahre.
Ich weiss,
wir sind alle nicht unendlich.
Und ... ja.
Irgendwann kommt die Zeit.
Aber ich will das
nicht vorwegnehmen,
den Kopf in den Sand stecken
und mir sagen:
"Ich weiss nicht, wie lange ich noch
lebe. Darum mache ich es nicht."
Deshalb umso mehr.
* Melancholische Musik *
Emmenbrücke.
Seit vier Monaten
ist Mireya wieder zu Hause.
Damit sie pünktlich
ihre Medikamente nehmen kann,
macht sie sich erst nach Schulbeginn
auf den Weg.
Ihre Mutter Katja denkt oft
an den unbekannten Organspender.
Früher bist aufgestanden,
bist arbeiten gegangen
und hast du gar nicht überlegt,
wie schön das Leben ist.
Und jetzt stehst du
jeden Morgen auf ...
Du kannst atmen, du kannst leben.
Du kannst in die Ferien. Du
kannst raus. Du kannst überall hin.
Bevor das passiert ist,
habe ich mir nie überlegt,
dass jeder Tag ein Glück ist.
Ich werde selbst einmal
Spenderin sein.
Das Problem ist aber, dass
die Leberkrankheit genetisch ist.
Der Arzt hat gesagt,
eine Niere könne ich spenden.
Aber die Leber nicht.
Mireyas Immunsystem ist gedrosselt -
wegen der Medikamente,
die eine Abstossung
des fremden Organs verhindern.
Ich muss mich eincrèmen.
Das Krebsrisiko ist wie bei allen
transplantierten Menschen erhöht.
Sie muss sich deshalb
gut gegen die Sonne schützen.
Siehst du? Jetzt kommt die Sonne.
Zum Glück haben wir dich eingecrèmt.
Mireya besucht die zweite Klasse.
Bald sind Sommerferien.
Mireya, ab der dritten Klasse
fahre ich dich nicht mehr.
Warum?
Das mache ich nur,
weil du Medikamente nehmen musst.
Nach und nach wird Mireya weniger
Medikamente zu sich nehmen müssen.
Früher
ist sie immer zu Fuss gegangen.
Ich habe sie nie gefahren.
Schon in der ersten Klasse.
Langsam muss sie wieder anfangen,
zu laufen.
(Lehrerin) Wir haben
verschiedene Zeichen kennengelernt.
Welche Zeichen
kennen wir in der Mathematik?
Plus.
- Das Plus.
Kann jemand ein Plus
an die Tafel zeichnen?
Genau.
Was zeichnen wir noch?
Geteilt durch.
- Das Geteilt-durch-Zeichen. Genau.
Im ersten Jahr
nach der Transplantation
ist die Gefahr von Komplikationen
noch erhöht.
Dann aber sind Mireyas Aussichten
auf ein fast normales Leben gut.
* Schulglocke *
Hab dich.
- Stimmt gar nicht, Elisa.
* Melancholische Musik *
Ausbildung, Beruf, Sport, Reisen
und in ihrem Fall
sogar eine eigene Familie -
all dem steht nichts im Wege.
Die behandelnden Ärztinnen
sind sicher,
dass die Transplantation bei Mireya
der richtige Schritt war,
obwohl die Krankheit
noch wenig erforscht ist.
Es gibt keinen Grund, zu befürchten,
dass es einen Rückfall gibt.
Diese Leber ist gesund.
Wir haben uns alle
für Mireya gefreut.
Und wahrscheinlich
haben wir früher schon Kinder
mit dieser Krankheit transplantiert,
ohne es zu wissen.
Und dort gab es nie Probleme.
Nein.
Ich bin zuversichtlich, dass die
Krankheit nicht zurückkommen wird.
Mit der Lebertransplantation kann
man Mireya effektiv ein Leben geben
ohne die Lebensbedrohung,
dass es morgen
wieder zu einem Leberversagen kommt,
das vielleicht beim dritten Mal
zum Tod von Mireya geführt hätte.
Martin Rast kommt für das Mittagessen
von der Arbeit nach Hause.
Hallo, Daddy.
Ausgerechnet heute
habe ich zwei Donuts gegessen.
Ich nehme gleich davon.
- Gleich zwei. Fertig.
Gut, haben wir die Hände gewaschen.
Warum?
Mit schmutzigen Händen
fasst man nichts an.
Mireya hat sich
von der Operation erholt.
Und auch die Eltern sind ruhiger.
Katja
hat eine Teilzeitstelle gefunden
und wird bald wieder arbeiten gehen.
(Christian Reutemann)
Da gibt's aber nur einen.
(Mann)
Wir können uns einen zweiten holen.
Jetzt machst du auch schon einen
auf Shopping-Queen?
Nein. Mieten.
Die Lungenkrankheit COPD
schränkt den Bewegungsradius
von Christian Reutemann ein.
Feld 15.
Alle Felder sind erntereif.
Nur in der virtuellen Welt
hat er Raum.
Er spielt oft im Team
mit Achim aus Berlin,
der vom Gamer-Kumpel
zum Freund geworden ist.
Das muss gesät werden.
Das ist noch nicht gemacht worden.
Achim?
Hörst du mich?
- Ja. Ich höre dich.
Ich habe vergessen, den Kopfhörer
anzuschalten.- Kann passieren.
Mir geht's gut. Und dir?
Ich kann nicht klagen.
Heute geht es mir wieder gut.
- Dann ist ja gut.
Rund 5 Std. pro Tag verbringt
Christian Reutemann mit Gamen -
oft zusammen mit Achim.
Ich sehe sofort, wie es Chris geht.
Ich höre es an der Stimme.
Ich sehe es,
wenn wir uns über Video sehen.
Ich sehe, wie es Chris geht.
Einmal bin ich deswegen auch
sofort zu ihm geflogen,
weil ich gemerkt habe,
dass es ihm nicht gut geht.
Meiner Lunge geht es auch nicht gut.
Ich kann nachfühlen,
wie es ihm geht. Das passt.
Ich kann nur sagen: Ich drücke ihm
die Daumen, dass es gut kommt.
* Achim spricht unverständlich. *
Okay. Danke für den Hinweis.
Oh. So.
Da ist alles abgeerntet.
Alle Felder.
Im richtigen Leben
lässt sich Christian Reutemann
die Lebensmittel liefern.
Selbst das Kochen
wird zur Anstrengung.
Und die Krankheit
bestimmt auch die Menüwahl.
Bei den Kohlehydraten
muss ich schauen,
dass ich nicht zu viel nehme -
wegen des Gewichts.
Es heisst, nur eine Handvoll.
Eine Heissluftfritteuse hilft,
Fett zu sparen.
Wenn man zu schwer ist, können sie
die Operation nicht durchführen.
Ein BMI von 30
sollte nicht überschritten werden.
Das bedeutet bei meiner Körpergrösse
ein Gewicht von unter 96 kg.
Jetzt bin ich bei 95 kg.
Ich habe das Ziel,
wieder etwas abzunehmen,
sodass ich auf 94 oder 93 kg komme.
Das ist optimal für die Operation.
Auch Christian Reutemann
ist IV-Rentner.
Denen habe ich 500 Stutz bezahlt.
Immer wieder wird er
von Panikattacken erfasst,
gerät in Atemnot, beginnt zu hecheln.
Und es dauert Stunden,
bis er sich beruhigt.
Wenn dies nicht gelingt,
ruft er die Ambulanz.
In diesem Jahr
musste ich drei-, vier-, fünfmal
mit der Ambulanz
nach Zürich gefahren werden.
50 % bezahlt die Krankenkasse.
Aber so ein Einsatz kostet
schnell mal 2'000 bis 2'500 Fr.
Dieser Betrag mal fünf ... Ich muss
viel aus eigener Tasche bezahlen.
* Schwere, düstere Musik *
Der Tod durch Ersticken,
durch langsames Ersticken,
macht mir Angst.
Das Ende dieser Krankheit.
Das ist mit ein Grund,
warum ich mich zum Schritt der
Transplantation entschieden habe.
Klar, es gibt heute Exit.
Damit habe ich mich aber
noch nicht auseinandergesetzt,
weil ich noch leben will.
Christian Reutemann
ist auf ein Spenderorgan angewiesen -
so wie 1'400 andere Menschen
in der Schweiz.
Seit Jahren bemüht sich der Bund,
die Spendebereitschaft
der Schweizerinnen und Schweizer
zu erhöhen.
Ohne durchschlagenden Erfolg.
Ich glaube, viele können sich
nicht vorstellen, wie das ist,
wenn man wirklich
ums Überleben kämpft.
Ich habe vor der Transplantation
auch nicht darüber nachgedacht,
einen Organspenderausweis
bei mir zu tragen.
Es gibt so viele Leute,
die grundsätzlich spenden würden.
Aber entweder weiss es niemand.
Oder es ist nirgends festgehalten.
Dann bringt es auch niemanden was,
wenn man eigentlich spenden wollte,
aber die Angehörigen
es am Ende nicht machen,
weil niemand Bescheid wusste.
Natürlich gibt es auch viele,
die denken,
sie wollen nicht angetastet werden
nach dem Tod,
sie wollen unversehrt bleiben.
Das sind alles valable Argumente.
Es gibt kein Richtig und Falsch.
In meinem nahen Familienumfeld
gibt es Leute,
die es sich nicht vorstellen können,
die Organe
nach einem Hirntod zu spenden.
Das ist okay. Aber sie
haben zumindest so entschieden.
Dann muss nicht ich entscheiden,
was er oder sie
hätten machen wollen.
Es ist eine Verantwortung
unseren Nächsten gegenüber.
Ja oder nein.
Im nationalen Organspenderegister,
das vor gut einem Jahr
aufgeschaltet wurde,
haben sich bis jetzt
70'000 Menschen eingetragen.
Ja oder nein.
Ein Entscheid steht auch
auf politischer Ebene an.
Eine Volksinitiative verlangt,
dass grundsätzlich
jeder Schweizer Spender ist,
wenn er sich nicht ausdrücklich
dagegen ausspricht.
Die wichtigste Botschaft ist:
Lasst euch informieren.
Lasst euch gut informieren.
Was heisst Spende?
Was heisst Transplantation?
Und entscheidet euch,
was ihr machen würdet,
wenn ihr mal ein Organ benötigt.
Und entscheidet auch,
was ihr machen würdet ...
Würdet ihr als Spender
ein Organ geben oder nicht?
Mireya Rast
lebt mit einem Spenderorgan.
Sie hat wie die Gleichaltrigen
kleine und grosse Träume.
Was möchtest du werden?
Wovon träumst du?
Da gibt es zwei Sachen.
- Ich weiss, was.
Für die Arbeit Tierärztin
oder ... ähm ...
Ärztin. Kinderärztin.
- Kinderärztin.
Und mein anderer Traum
ist ein Welpe.
Das habe ich mir schon gedacht.
Ein Welpe als Gesellschaft für Rocco.
Für mich ... ja.
Dann kommt noch einer dazu.
* Hoffnungsvolle, perlende Musik *
Sobald jemand so krank ist,
betrachtet man die Gesundheit nicht
mehr als so selbstverständlich.
Man muss es geniessen.
Jetzt schauen wir in die Zukunft.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *